hmm
do you understand why i called you here
tonight
look
i thought we were good
it's all on the contract
no
you're never good with the devil walrus
[Music]
stephen you can't direct you're in
quarantine
yeah [ __ ] you stephen
[Laughter]
[Music]
dot com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
channel
[Music]
strangers
[Music]
[Music]
i hope that's not a sponsor ahoy
wow that's terrible luna did you teabag
that
just
tasted like
ode de luna balls south of the border
anyway uh good to be here
ahoy everybody welcome to the show uh it
is a live show monday through thursday
at 10 a.m eastern uh you can check us
out on rumble anywhere where you find
podcasts as well as of course mug club
and uh you know feel free to go over to
rumble that way
uh
[Laughter]
or more importantly louderwood dot com
slash mug club
question of the day
what do you think a boss [ __ ] is
uh i think it's j lo but i don't know so
go ahead comment what is a boss [ __ ] is
it me is it you i don't know let us know
in the comments section we need a little
help with that question we do because i
don't know what a boss [ __ ] is beyonce
oh maybe you know where you must be able
to find out is when uh you and i even do
some shows we got some dates coming up
oh almost everything is is completely
sold out i think i think didn't we
release like a handful of additional
tickets in detroit we did for this
weekend
we pulled a handful of comps if somebody
wants to go royal oak week boom royal
michigan real local that's why i'm
wearing this shirt shirt it's right wolf
shirt but so we have actually pike's
peak in pikes peak colorado i think it's
colorado springs area roughly in june
18th the early show still has some
tickets left but that's going to sell
out i know it's june and you're like oh
it's june and i got time you don't have
time no don't get on top of it
no time buy the power
piece right and dave you've got some
dates coming up as well right i do i got
may 6th in gileo's theater in
springfield missouri there's no way i
pronounced that right no may 7th i'll be
in lincoln nebraska but more importantly
may 27th 28th the big l's emily
minnesota big l is awesome huge fan of
the show
really good dude uh really
great food at the place too fantastic
either buy a ticket to one of these
shows or maybe get welded into your
house yeah your choice uh it's cool if
you're maybe you're a communist which is
an easy thing to do when you're free and
full
and stupid
anyway so
good good to be here i'd like to
introduce everybody gerald a good
morning ahoy how are you sir i'm good
i'm living you're living yeah barely
good you can go out and get food and the
basic necessities of life uh i can uh
much higher price obviously with
inflation but yeah
yes gas is higher so is bread i love it
we don't count that though no i only eat
bread
token now
tim the tool man
i'm happy to see in the third chair
quarter black era hey two days in a row
guys wow hey two days in a row no
wait no it's not even on me
i feel like i should just call him
garrett now this is just racist stop all
right there he is what's up g what's up
man i'm glad to be here i'm glad you're
here on the show with you hosting i'm
excited i know it's been too long no too
long
it's been and of course fourth chair
crawdaddy himself is it fourth i'm i'm
moving gradually moving out the door no
i'm guessing no
it's still playing third and 33 and a
third like naked gun second third chair
i guess we'll call it yes please welcome
darren crowder papa crowder yeah
thank you springfield missouri isn't
that where they film the simpsons
i don't know i think it's supposed to be
it could be ohio though yeah live in
springfield nobody would never know
never know it's one of the midwestern
ohio springs one of the springfield sure
yeah we know this for sure marge's hair
always obscured the map when they were
pointing out which springfield there
that was always the gag
they uh they shouldn't be high-top fade
it was good yeah that was a good show
until like 15 years ago yeah until
yeah of jumped the shark 15 years ago is
that when conan left yes okay i i love
the first 17 seasons
yeah it's great you couldn't end it
there guys
yeah the show is almost as old as me all
right so
uh this isn't actually an exciting thing
i got all peppy about it but a guy who i
have met was one of the nicest people
i've ever met and one of the funniest
people uh yesterday the legendary and i
do mean legendary gilbert godfrey passed
away at the age of 67 uh due to
complications uh from
myotonic why would you put this in the
map like i could read dystrophy
dystrophy well
i know it's a rare muscle disease uh
it's a bit like ms
yeah i it's just i should have said rare
muscle disease
but uh gilbert was hilarious when i was
on the anthony comey show i we got to
work with him a couple times and he's
just
just one of the funniest people legend
man
amazing and you guys honor him on this
show constantly well steven does
probably the best gilbert impression in
the history
of uh mankind oh yeah it's really good
yeah so uh we wanted to take a second
and just uh talk about you know
obviously what a talented guy was but
let's also look at him
on the apprentice
what did you think of geraldo gilbert as
your project manager i thought he did a
great job unless you thought he did a
bad job in which case he was terrible
he's principal sure how i felt about his
puerto rican site but his jew side as
with a hundred percent
how did you find gilbert he was a
different kind of a guy i thought at
first he was going to be like mr magoo
kind of like blindly bumping into walls
and you know uh going in phasing in and
out of character but i must say when
push come to shove gilbert guthrie
really stuck up to the play he really
did he got
he's there he got no one likes him
he's a surprising and easily here's
where our troops are by the way yeah oh
yeah i have to give out military secrets
yes
you are here we are there
um
one of my favorite ever appearances of
gilbert was actually in the roast of
hugh hefner when he had to go up after
iced tea
gilbert godfrey
[Applause]
[Music]
oh this evening went by so quick
it just seemed like it started 50 hours
ago and here i am you know everyone else
it's so bad coming on after this because
everyone else did my act already
it's like iced tea did my whole uh act
right now so i'll do it anyway i'm gonna
follow you white [ __ ] home
and rape you
wow
you see it's such a strong beat it still
works
he's just the funniest dude ever it
turned into more of an iced tea roasted
and if you if uh you're at home and the
kids aren't around read
or watch gilbert godfrey reads [ __ ]
the greatest video it is so funny isn't
it okay it's so good so uh yeah rest in
peace gilbert that's just uh absolute
shame and i just another person who's uh
joined the just tons of comments we've
lost a lot in the last few years yeah
nor mcdonald's saggit louis anderson
just like recently yeah
there was a post and i don't know if i
saw you like it or not but like
retweeted not like like yeah i mean but
uh where i think gottfried said that uh
you know these two people being in the
picture sagat and and uh uh louis dying
and said yeah it's sad and then somebody
actually posted like this is really sad
now because all three people in the
picture yeah
picture with those two guys and saying
ah it's sad that i lost my friends and
that wasn't that long ago no so a couple
months jeez no it's just a shame man
yeah a lot of ogs
yeah rest in peace yeah yeah
um
the the tweet that they sent out by the
way was really good the family was like
look laugh because that's what he wanted
people to not laugh at this but just
laugh
and enjoy what he did and what he
provided to the world so we're not
trying to be a downer he was one of the
few guys that could
part of his bit part of his his whole
persona was laughing at himself and
having so much fun all the time he was
infectious i mean you just get drawn in
by it well it was such a great
great character yeah that he could be
anything and like one of the best bits
ever is on the norm mcdonald's show when
he's talking about what he would do to
angelina or not um what's her
name for what disease and that's not his
fault michael douglas opened up that
candidate he did he started yeah he said
it's how he got throat cancer and then
he's like i would get spina bifida
spider-man
ms he would just shout out diseases
anything yes just so brilliant and he
was very uh off camera he was very kind
of very meek and not
vocal yeah guy but the character that he
had was just so brilliant yeah and just
so
angry but not really yeah that's why i
think it works so well in stephen's
impression of uh
oh now i'm forgetting why am i
forgetting sanders
bernie sanders my this is this is a good
idea right i'm hoping steven's not
watching right now now bernie sanders is
not it's it's hilarious because bernie
is like this angry sounding guy and what
he's saying a lot of times and it just
it works but it yeah it was such a great
character honestly
i didn't know
that that was a character i didn't
follow like comedy like you guys
followed comedy i just thought that's
how the guy sounded most of the time oh
yeah right and it's like oh no that's
that's something a little different like
you obviously would have been able to
see that if you had done any paying
attention which i didn't but i was like
oh my gosh that makes it even better for
me how do you keep your voice doing that
yeah all the time and he was just the
filthiest comic imaginable
that's probably why i didn't watch him
as much you loved it i was like i'll go
back and watch bill cosby because he's
moral he's one of those characters that
like i knew him because i was a kid at
the time from like aladdin that was the
only thing i knew him from yeah and then
affleck commercials and then later on i
was like oh this guy is raunchy like i
love this this is hilarious yeah and
they kicked him off the affleck
commercial he kicked him off and some
joke about he was like do you know who
he was canceled early on yeah yeah we
got cancelled on a roast because it was
right after 9 11 and he said i'm sorry
i'm late i had a layover at the empire
state building and it was like the day
after
i realized not too soon home aren't
laughing i don't care oh yeah it's so
good it's funny i don't care you find
light in the darkness yes that one
podcast episode with artie lange
steve oh yeah literally he's in tears
the entire time and a lot of it is just
them laughing
it's it's not even it's just they're
just having a good time artie and and
him would go back and forth
probably harder and funnier than anybody
i've ever seen two people do it was
brilliant
just brilliant
and yeah it's just tragic and yeah rest
in peace
man sucks
on uh on a happier note
cam newton was still getting mobbed on
twitter yesterday
after his appearance on the podcast
million dollars worth of game
my parents have been together for 36 37
years now and stupid if you had white
parents uh i grew up in a three-parent
household my mom was a crocodile dude
that's my grandmother and they all and
uh i knew what that doctor murray a
woman was not a bad [ __ ]
okay what's the difference a woman okay
a bad [ __ ] is careful
a person who's just
careful you know
girl i'm a bad [ __ ] you know i'm doing
this i'm doing it i'm actually doing the
nails
yeah but i don't act apart okay you know
and it's a lot of danger women who are
bad [ __ ] and i say [ __ ] in in a
way not to degrade a woman
but
just to to to go off the aesthetic of
what they deem is a boss chick now
a woman for me is
handling your own but knowing how to
cater to
[Music]
cater a man's needs
oral
don't know how to allow a man to lead oh
my gosh
i mean look he's right hey
it's definition it's definition i'm very
confused about his whole get up though
he's got like the crocodile dundee hat
then like a superman shirt from like 98
yep and then the white shirt on the
outside
like garrett he's what's he doing he's
fashion forward
right he doesn't to distract from the
awful things he says
[Laughter]
distract distract yeah
not work
this of course caused an uptick in
worldwide virtue signaling oh yeah yeah
[Music]
there it is oh oh the blue check marks
coming oh yeah oh i'll just read them
yeah i'm trying like hell to not give
oxygen to cam newton and his comments
because they're so blatantly ridiculous
but i keep coming back to the fact that
they're so
or that they're also dangerous because
they contribute to a culture that
believe it's okay to demean and devalue
women gotta do better cam said reporter
jim trotter do better shut up jim you
[ __ ] all right so anyway
what's cooking skills that's not a
demeaning thing no
being able to cook is great women cook
better
[Laughter]
anyway
uh and then who else talked oh
patriarchy blues author frederick joseph
said again many men such as cam newton
need to read more and speak less the
level of misogyny and sexism on these
podcasts is disgusting disgusting
disgusting
he then logged onto you porn
so five notes three minutes after
tweeting this right he's like this is
disgraceful can't believe it gusting
where's my neck on girl i uh
does anyone does anyone watch the
million dollars podcast
whoever came up with the term dallas did
have a lot of them
or not well it may have the irs could
have took him
[Laughter]
like that guys very likely on the mtv
omtv raps or no the
uh show where they show off their
mansions
oh yeah cribs yeah crips like i got this
this and this and the irs is like you
claimed 30 grand last year yeah you have
nine bentleys i put it all on snap
see my fridge look at this
i got a lot of snaps it's raining
yeah yeah that was that was all a setup
that was a the best sting operation ever
yeah that's what it should have been
just eom tv stinging crazy what's up
with all these you've got a lot of pas
here they're all wearing fbi shirts
what's up with that yeah that's crazy
padlocking cribs how much did you pay
for that again
oh really oh that's interesting
notice yes this is for the vo later yeah
yeah
the twitter mob though in this case of
course failed to mention that cam
critiqued men within the same episode
i'm not just about to sit up there and
beat up my my queen no that's right yeah
i'm also gonna gonna also
tell the men to start being men bro
absolutely
that that sucker should not be rewarded
that's on point though that is really on
point like yes he's saying hey be men
and women be women and be able to
support each other like what what is so
wrong with that there's nothing it's a
great so statement i mean it's very
confusing i'll tell you what like what's
wrong with it it makes a lot of sense
this guy is completely unaware of what
he's putting out there or he's fully
aware
he says he has a great example of his
father being first of all being in the
home big win yeah that's great he
fathered four kids
otto wedlock never married the girl what
kind of leadership is that
is it the same the gal he's with left
him because he fathered a fifth kid
with uh some instagram model
i mean come on this practice guys
exactly that's not leadership i'm
looking around here and i know
every guy in here great example great
father
come on he can't he can't churn that out
and think anyone's going to buy it yeah
all you have to do is a little search on
cam and he is uh
he's just he's way off base there's
there's no way yeah he's saying the
right thing yeah but you first cam you
first yeah about that living it i think
that's that's a fair point right i mean
he's a very fair point he's got five
children he's not married and he's not
being the example yeah he says he was
given not modeling that i mean if you're
gonna impregnate an instagram model you
you're thinking more tick tock would be
appropriate i'm just glad that he says
to don't beat women because it's
following in the stellar lineup well he
doesn't know who he doesn't know who he
works for he doesn't know that the
league is is much more
apt to
be okay with a colin kaepernick than
they would with comments like that yeah
exactly
they're better with the
the race stuff than they are with some
guy who they view as massages right of
course yeah well they have the dallas
cowboy cheerleaders he'll never he'll
never work again no
but
you know great talent right ray rice
that's right
but a great talent i mean
just yeah we'll just keep naming names
yeah
o.j simpson bryant brian thomas chad
johnson all right anybody else
did i put a damper on things no i'm
sorry no i think you're right i was just
trying to cheer it up by name and wife
hey gals follow my lead it's almost like
a league of wife beaters adam jones
they're putting together a team just
keep going just keep going yeah they
don't
know
about your emails
yeah they do like to beat women but
that's okay not not okay to do no but
they say if you can't leave it that's
okay because they can sign another
contract right after that i always say
as long as you can cook
ah that's right yeah you can cook the
steak and you're holding your eye
so
all right i'm hungry start cooking it
now yeah there you go it's not gonna
work it's gonna thought out
all right but maybe he's struggling to
articulate something important the loss
of meaning that comes from
rural fulfillment and
modernity i think so we talk about this
all the time that was my point i didn't
just read it
yeah but you wrote it for yourself yeah
yeah yeah you surprised yourself yeah i
was like
i know what that means yeah how did i do
that no we talk about the roll thing all
the time here just to kind of tie a bow
on this like that's that's what we see i
like a buttery roll going away not like
going like that like cinnamon
it's falling into the drizzle oh hello
i'm sorry i didn't mean to adopt you i'm
on a diet i can't help it you said it
about it cinnabon right yeah that's too
much cinnabon uh no i think we we lose
that because there are complimentary
roles and we talk about men and women as
being interchangeable now like that
there's no difference between them and
that's not that's never true in these
situations it doesn't mean that you
don't have the same dignity it doesn't
mean that you don't have in some cases
the same abilities but it does mean that
you're going to be better at certain
things than the other role the other
gender is yeah so it's like the tweet
implying that having a certain role in
supporting your spouse is demeaning in
some way that's not demeaning fulfilling
it's fulfilling and and
in fact it's the opposite it's it's
empowering to have a role and be able to
complete that role that's right and you
have that for both men and women and to
to demean that
is is gross to me like what that
reporter blue check mark whoever the
check mark yeah and he was struggling to
articulate with the misuse it's very
hard to follow
he's talking about ladies that are
walking around you know doing this and
doing you said clacking over yeah
yeah exact squid hands who is going to
be attracted to that ladies like i think
that's one of the cam's points is like
look don't don't walk around acting like
that's the thing to aspire to it's not
and men be followable that's what we
need we need men who are worthy of being
followed right both are true and women
in those relationships are willing to do
that to say i you know what this works
really well if i have somebody as a
partner that i can follow if you're not
follow women don't don't expect it i i
love when guys go home and they're like
oh my wife doesn't listen to me i'm like
i wouldn't either you're an idiot yes
but i ask you this
how many straight men can pull off a
neckerchief go
yeah only paul lind and him have ever
won
and the guy from
scooby-doo
who was always what bank of salmon
that's what's up that's uh that's an
ascot yeah yeah was that an ascot for
him i think so i think it was too young
for an ascot that's true he doesn't have
a boat no
he's just a kid he's got a van
too
my dog solves mysteries you want to get
in
want to be a part of a show kid yeah hey
triple decker sandwiches in here bro get
in here i'm from disney he folded his
sandwich like a deck of guards and then
molested me all right
[Laughter]
said it was a mystery
he said figured out who done it i said
you i'm watching
yeah so it's him cam newton and paul
linde are the three people that have
worn neckerchief one of them is a
fictional character will let you guess
who yes
cam newton
[Laughter]
no i i get what everybody's saying and
that's how we move on that's called a
segway
uh i used to live in a great place
called new york and i don't know if you
guys have heard it's not very nice right
now
i think you typically don't make it past
too many lyrics no yeah let's just get
beat up and this is dave saying it's a
bad place to live he's from detroit yes
yeah
anywhere in detroit in new york there's
no subway in detroit that's right
there's a sandwich subway it's the
motorcycles
but you can't get on no subway when i
was people don't die if there's a subway
in detroit when i was a kid in detroit
if you drove a foreign car they were
waiting in the overpass with you either
a bowling ball or a piece of concrete to
time to go right through your window
yeah now they're just doing it to any
car that's everything that's the
difference
yeah we only do japanese cars yes now
it's just well they didn't throw them at
their own because they're all mexican
made
i'm kidding the f-150 is built there i
think still yeah
american-made did we have a stinger i
was waiting on that and it just didn't
happen
i particularly love that guy who's
walking into like the deli seeing
somebody get beat up he's like yeah
whatever i gotta get my it's new york
i'm hungry i gotta get a drink
i absolutely would have done that
i'm not even gonna lie let's just walk
past like yeah oh no somebody getting
their head bashed against a car i'd be
like gentlemen
good morning
this deli for a cuban sandwich made of
old meats
i i could be out here in a minute with
you yes bang my head into the fine i'll
see you in five please don't hurt me i
don't carry cash
that's
oh they do like their change there oh
they do
coins sexes
so anyway
in new york surprising to no one new
york is still an absolute cesspool
yesterday 10 brooklyn subway commuters
were shot by a deranged man dressed in a
construction vest and gas mask
oh that's how he got past security yeah
i'm on the construction crew that
doesn't there's nobody who cares
nobody's watching anything why do you
have a gas mask on sir yeah they're more
effective than the surgical masks oh i
you know it's just
construction have you seen my vest that
i was wearing oh don't ask me questions
yeah okay oh you're a gas man
constructioner by the way i have a giant
bag of guns yeah yeah oh pay attention
to that i i started a question and this
smoke grenade go on
uh 13 additional people were injured
during the attack um this is um a video
of the aftermath you might want to get
the kids out of the room there don't
look at it
oh it's you know what it is it's the
36th street i bet you that's uh
that's a train that goes right through
times square
[Music]
glad they're all wearing mask though yes
it's protective
well it's probably more effective
against that
stopped bullets this is just so
disgusting
oh that guy's limping he shot me i think
he's the one that survived
this is unbelievable
jeez
all defenseless
yeah question uh subway
gun-free zone yeah uh the entire city of
new york
is he didn't see the sign he's a problem
no he's if he saw the sign we need to
make bigger signs that's the problem
that's the problem the construction crew
though guys i mean was it in his
language though
well
oh that's a good point
no guns here bro yeah
oh man no guns i can i can't shoot
people here mm-hmm
it's the man criminals work they follow
the rules they do they do it was uh
turned out to be 60-year-old frank james
and he's been the suspect identified
right here uh he was identified by a
credit card found at the scene which uh
was used to rent a u-haul that was found
nearby
wow yep james had apparently been on the
fbi's terror watch list until 2019. they
he dropped his credit card by the way
yeah what were you doing swiping while
shooting people like i'm sorry
guys i'm hungry uber eats yeah just
dropped your wallet in the kitchen what
i was ordering a sandwich
there's a deli at the next stop
it's unbelievable uh the motive is still
being reported as unknown ah i wonder if
we can guess
there are a couple of options i think
are there we'll see
i don't know social media uh believed to
it was linked to some stuff uh like he
had a particular world view oh oh well
so was it trump supporter no no no
is that jesse
that's the
uh that one in the middle there fan of
the hodge twins yeah nice art he loves
bleach apparently i guess that's four
people that wore a neck never mind uh
and his uh last youtube video uploaded
on april 11th 2022 makes his position
explicit he writes this is what they do
ultimately through the day they kill
they commit genocide against each each
other what do you think they can't
what do you think they gonna do to your
black ass
that's your friend
you got a white friend really
they're gonna kill you
they're gonna kill you
no they're gonna toss you first they're
gonna [ __ ] you up first real good what
kind of white friends do you have this
right now in ukraine torturing and
binding and killing and stabbing and
raping women and cutting your throat
what do you what do you think they're
going to do to you if they get you to
hold you they need to be a lot mother
more [ __ ] straight bullets
a lot more [ __ ] you die by
straight
[ __ ] that
the [ __ ] it's going to transform
into something else it has to cannot
stay the same
he's work on his setup yeah he better
lightening it's gonna be something
that's good my grandma said the same on
her desk
there's gonna be reversal of all your
fortunes no
you're not a man of the brother
you're a slave
wow
wow the more you know
where's that rainbow dave motive still
unknown yeah i'm not sure what it was
i do think stepping onto a train mostly
filled with asians though will fix the
problem yeah yeah that's probably going
to destroy the narrative yeah
i'll do it riding alone riding along a
track they built i'm a little confused
he's he's talking about a war going on
between people that are white saying
that this is what's going to happen
to you he's like that's what they do to
the white people what they gonna do to
you well hold on i'm a little confused
is russia or or and or ukraine going to
invade the united
states are they like god next stop usa
you know like what's i don't understand
the point here it doesn't make yeah
that's uh yeah it's a scholar it's
allegorical ah yeah thank you you know
what garrett do me a favor will you
please translate what we just heard
that's i just did i thought you said
if this is what white people do to white
people what they're gonna do to you
that's basically what you're saying yeah
yeah cause russia is interested i can i
can hear him i'm here he never went to
ukraine yeah i decipher cam newton i
could decipher him too i got it
i kind of see why you're on the show
today i think i think the internet needs
to be taken and put on a shelf like this
it's like a break you can have it back
when you all learn how to behave yeah
because this isn't for you guys this is
ridiculous well it took a break that
video was shot the day before yeah the
day before i believe so
i don't want it on it april 11th so if
that's the actual date it was it was
actually put up i don't know but that's
that's insane
he got real mad at the viewership
well
i gotta tell you though the ninja
turtles lazy pieces of [ __ ] yeah they're
not doing their job
like the subway that is your place like
that's your stopping ground
nothing now yeah
we just get a hockey stick wielding at
this point i think they're like uh 40
year old
ninja turtles that's what i mean they
pee in their teens they probably don't
want to go up there they're like we're
mutants we had a lot of pizza yeah slow
yeah
all the cheese only pizza since 1985.
yeah a rat that can talk yeah who's been
dead for a while and we don't know where
to put him
he just put him in the corner over there
and splinter died in 98.
it's been been a long time he still
speaks to me though it's weird yeah he
does karate in his cage get a lot of
knee injuries from all the skateboarding
yeah a lot of that and other stuff to
make money yeah that's why we have the
pads
and that is new york state of mind
[Music]
yeah you what's up babies thanks for
tuning in
how you doing i'm good i'm good yeah
how are you doing good
daddy how are you hanging in i'm hanging
in yeah i'm excited i love it when a
detroit guy says well that's really a
hell hole yeah
yeah man
it went from the nice like it wasn't i
shouldn't say nice it went from a decent
area though to where i would have to
play like feces hopscotch to walk to the
train you're like because there was just
crap everywhere it was human beings too
oh yeah it wasn't dog
you know it was like then you do that to
get to the train and then on the train
it's like you're either getting some guy
who's screaming it's
what he thinks is the bible at you in a
different language yeah next to a guy
who's like playing keytar with his dick
out and you're like
i'm confused i think i'm going to uber
[Laughter]
you know when giuliani ran that town the
streets sparkled and i don't it was
beautiful i mean sparta yeah he he asked
the shop owners to pressure wash they're
just the area in front of their business
and they all it was unbelievable do you
know what he did wrong though and i and
i would say this too he ran the homeless
out of town no he ran the mob out of
town yeah they would not take this guff
for a second
you're gonna put what 20 crackheads in
front of a nightclub that a mobster owns
you can't have this
they're like hey what do you think we
should do about this they're like
they'll be gone tonight i don't worry
about it don't worry about where they're
gonna go yeah don't worry about don't
ask questions well we got a truck out of
the suburbs yeah somewhere yeah
somewhere nice somewhere
just think about on the island you know
what i mean like a garbage bag of cats
but it's bums
[Laughter]
nobody's going to miss them what kind of
what what you never hit a bomb with a
club
yeah you got to learn them i don't even
try to dodge it
can you imagine the guy gets on a train
with a gun and there's just six
gangsters on there they're like oh
they just do that turn around you sure
you really want to do this yeah oh look
there's a guy in a mask and they're cute
yeah yeah yeah
i trained
calling us no fredo go over there and
slap them
i don't know if you guys heard this the
the disney air is trans what yeah an
heiress to disney yeah yeah i don't even
know i'm not sure hold the kevin spacey
that's a gendered term what happened
with that well you know whenever kevin
spacey all the allegations came out all
of a sudden he was gay oh that's right
there's a little heat on disney boys we
have a trans though that we got to look
at our trans that did not work i didn't
know it didn't yeah cause he's like uh
you sexually assaulted a 14 year old in
kevin's space he's like i'm gay he's
like what
kevin i'm gay though the only
heterosexual why would i do that why
would i do that that's absurd that's
insane but instead he was like i like
men and you're like okay he's like well
do i need to go further i hear this uh
this one person killed someone and then
they changed and uh you let that one go
do i need to go that far yeah is that
cool can i try to fit my hand into a
glove well it gets people off you have
to make eerie christmas videos for the
rest of time
he has done that
consistently uh he didn't stop no he
reminds people that he might be guilty
every christian every single time if he
just stopped it it would be fine we'd go
like we kind of probably would forget
i'm not sure i've seen this
i've never seen you you've never seen
the kevin oh he has some meltdown every
christmas change video does he really
yeah he puts them on himself can we see
that on mug club can we bring that up
yes yes please yeah i don't think i've
seen this yet that's awesome oh yeah
he's a psycho he loves his mind
he is john doe now he's still a rich
person he could just move somewhere yeah
you know can money really buy uh your
reputation to be cleaned
i'm sorry sexually it doesn't buy you
sanity for sure do you think he was like
really caring so much about his
reputation when he was sexually
assaulting the no because it was 1985
yeah that was way before his reputation
then he built it up ah so he didn't have
it then yeah great minds hey okay
you know not much no no they're not over
here right here though do you know and
under the sea he did most of the singing
and that's all i have
oh is bobby darin yeah did you know
bobby darin threw his wife through a
coffee table so he could play for the
nfl
full circle full circle
if that was that correct that would be
uh very interesting it's like all right
now look at the form here you know the
original name of mac the knife was smack
the wife
that makes sense
in that era what a good joke that just
fell flat
i felt it but i was drinking it yeah it
was thinking it was i don't know i
wouldn't have done spit take i was put
on the fields for not knowing about the
spaces you didn't know mac the knife oh
i'm not telling you that you're bad for
not knowing spacey's crazy christmas
videos i'm saying i'm happy that i can
introduce them to you yes yes yes it's
not it's not pretend that's a bad thing
yeah it's a good thing all right it's
not christmas without crazy spacey oh no
just didn't feel the same are you
familiar darren i am yeah they're great
aren't they and i love how you spun that
rhyme right off of a classic uh
thank you bobby darren saw i think i
could have been named after bobby darren
and just because of the spelling really
usually people are r e n or two r's e n
minus two r's ion oh yeah parents would
have maybe uh would have been their hero
they'd be a fan yeah he well he died in
his 30s too he had some like heart well
maybe that's a goodness yeah i think
it's called being a musician
so
uh yes the the heir of disney uh charlie
cora so that clears that up
has publicly come out as a transgender
person cora's stepfather is the grandson
of disney co-founder
oh my goodness i'll remove it i'm royal
disney hi hi hey
make a wish
come to my lucky disney
you were expecting walt but you got me
oh it's unlucky for you johnny
oh roy or disney i'll go go on my racist
ride
it's a small world isn't here anymore
that's one ride it's potato famine
there's that time
look at the babies all right uh it's
called the wee lad yes it's a wheel it's
a queen lads world it's a paddy wagon
filled with black so
roy
this was v1 he changed it all up to go
to what we see now
just this completely ghetto disney it's
all run down they only sell like fully
loaded potatoes to eat that's it that's
all they have sorry sir we're closed
fully loaded potatoes yeah mashed
potatoes and alcohol baked potatoes how
come the only ride is say bye to my
father whose liver is failing
it's just amazing grace and bagpipes on
a loop
playing through the park
oh danny boy
the pipes the pipes
i mean how removed is this gal though
from the line i mean her step father's
grandson of the co-founder not even
wally directly that's what i'm saying
they brought it's a trophies
it's a token they go oh look we also
have a trance i don't think that's an
heirloom
either financially or yeah they did the
kevin spacey she probably got a phone
call and was like i'm related to who
or oh i guess i'll get that i have no
idea how much money you want to throw at
me oh i'll go up on stage no hey yeah
i'm trans and i'm a millionaire
apparently
it's a hail mary because like the
after all this controversy with disney
that one of their ceos came out and said
that two of their kids are gender
non-conforming who knew and then another
ceo that's running the mcu came out and
we're at the glad awards saying oh we
need more representation in kids films
more representation and now they're
doing look we're going to roll our
trains out look at them see
we are accepting we're allies and then
they had bob uh chapek the ceo of disney
come out and do a big apology tour going
i'm so sorry i wasn't a good enough ally
to you i'm so sorry it's all fake it's
all fake it's just to try to make you
yeah forget that they they don't
actually care about you let's remember
this as we get to the next segment about
disney and speaking up for those those
oppressed classes yeah disney we'll
we'll see how thanking the that yes the
camps in in china
literally thinking that the the leaders
of thank you the camps
in china yeah
they're it's horrible they're day camps
that they yeah it's a fun church they do
activities you know like not eat
well that's right
about lb about ron desantis's awesome
parental rights bill and its effect on
lgbtq
plus youth
oh man too many letters to remember it's
a lot they keep them to put something
like this law on top of that they can't
learn about their community and their
history at school or play sports or use
the bathroom they want to use yes that's
not true they can play sports and they
can use the bathroom they can use any
bathroom you like so it's a bathroom of
my choice
yeah that's the name it's the name of my
new album brave dave bathroom of my
choice brave dave brave dave yeah anyway
the whole article is incredibly
complicated to read take this paragraph
for example
cora who told the times that they don't
have much experience with public
speaking or advocacy lamented that they
don't do very much to help
yeah right because you said plural words
there's nothing that works and
we understand all the words individually
but in and comedy the syntax there it
just doesn't fit no it makes no sense
that was that was used a translator was
used on that yeah i believe word for
word translation or something maybe it
was like he's not going to judge
you definitely should yes
it's not just core that's doing some
transitioning though after such a huge
financial loss uh disney is doing a
little rebranding of their own that
brings us to today's seven plus one
renamed disney attractions
[Music]
every time you were on a hot mic just
then i always forget it i did say that
number seven gerald's 101
peter pan sexual's flight
great ride
number six qb
splash mount him
oh
[Laughter]
did elon make this yeah number four
darren
cherry popping
put some flavor on that one
number three the little spermate oh come
on
a whole new world no photoshop nated on
number two gerald how dare you
poke a hot ass there you go
tell that to your god
number one qb
snow white and the seven seven-year-olds
oh it's on brand oh
man
oh it's because it's real
and then uh plus one we got one more
here we go the many adventures of
winnie's
oh pooper got hair on his chest look at
that oh no
he's a bear after all go ahead and brim
around in the hell bother
and that's seven plus one
[Music]
always one in the chamber we're always
trying to remind you not to but you
always forget every time every time
there's always i'm in the time reminding
i'm done i'll keep trying i'm sorry i
didn't know there were almost been years
but we keep not next time we're gonna
check for winnie's pooper
that's where they keep the extra that's
where the extra chamber yeah
it's that one in the chamber that's in
the herd of a lot of celebrities that's
true
[Music]
that's why i play
russian roulette with all the bullets
i have a two-sided two-headed coin
uh-huh i don't go first no
so
wow
anywho
speaking of security
there's some exciting news in airport
security the dallas left field airport
has a robot named scott who watches
passengers to ensure they're wearing
masks and not loitering in their cars
let's have a look
welcome to dallas love field airport
all ubers lifts
taxis and rental car shuttles are
located on the lower level
to access the lower level please use an
escalator or elevator to proceed
downstairs
did i mention he sounds a tad effeminate
that shocked i did not see that video
before almost cartoonish
so that's real you can find your flights
in terminal d yes when did brian stelter
start doing voiceover robot
limp wrists yes
well it's funny he actually it did short
circuit and uh it caused this to happen
hey
i want to dance with somebody
[Music]
[Music]
oh what a zesty nightmare oh that must
have really pissed off a lot of people
yeah it did actually it really did and
i'll tell you what really got upset uh
his android parents
sent him off to gay christian robot
conversion camp yeah he just finished
the program and hears him now
[Music]
i mean
yeah i think i'm glad to see that he's
reformed pray that once and zero's away
yeah
i guess he just got busted by an ecstasy
off an undercover roomba ah he had a
bunch of condoms on him
it's high on e yeah it's a shame so
shanghai
china
shaolin right what's happening in the
old eastern countries
well are they in the news dave no they
are i don't know if you heard uh they
have massive lockdowns uh yesterday the
us consulate in shanghai ordered the
departure of all non-emergency staff and
family members that's pretty groovy okay
chinese foreign ministry spokesperson
hold on
zhao legene
[Laughter]
no it is it's i made sure it was right i
wrote it down on my separate paper
separate paper
separate but equal paper
because it's it's spelled all terrible
rule
don't do it it's all stupid
it is though it doesn't make any sense
it doesn't say that
there's like a z
j's in there what's going on they threw
some silverware in the air and whatever
sound it made when it came to you
hold on hold on time can we can we just
bring up cnn real quick look this is
this is frank ah they just moved on from
it but this is frank they were talking
he posted a video here's what they said
about people who have uh who he thinks
or have presumably hurt him didn't say
he was talking about white people yeah
it was kind of targeted
that we did it was very targeted nobody
in that booth went like ah he said white
people are going to do this to you as
well sorry i don't want to sidetrack us
i know we have to we have a guest
journal this guy looks like a rock if he
sold his muscles
deflated
i'm the pebble what is it yeah
do you smell what i'm cooking no no no
then
all right not enough spices
emotional damage i'm going to sit in the
car cold walking small
um
so joe joe macau said chinese strongly
dissatisfied and uh firmly opposed the
us's uh uh you know put his why don't
you read that journal politicization of
the evacuation
[Music]
he also asked the us to stop attacking
china's covet prevention policies and
using the virus as an excuse to smear
the country because that's the excuse
china's largest city reported just over
23 000 cases on tuesday ah the footage
out of china showing the mental and
physical damage these lockdowns are
causing is heartbreaking
this really is sad uh if you have kids
to get them out of the room it's very
sad
they're screaming because they can't
leave the apartment just yelling out of
their balconies
well they've been taped into their
apartments yes if they're lucky
and they're starving
it's for your protection sir
we must beat they were beating the
greater good before this by the way i
think that's what you get into science
foreign
beating the crap out of a grown man next
to a playground oh that's cool that's
going to be going the bag of cats
that's the hottest new christmas gift
this year dave yeah this is bagel cats
yeah
he was catching dinner guys
hey is that a bus
i'm sorry you don't know that they eat
pets sometimes
i'm sorry that is that the tape's
breakable
this is disgusting why like
how do you can't they rise up let's do
something well they're they're a billion
of them so at some point you think they
have yeah
yeah but they don't have sticks like
that the bigger the government the
smaller the man
this guy's got balls to stand up stand
up to his government what happened to
that perfect form kata
oh wow
it doesn't work that way and
under your uh
you need to work on that yeah they were
really into karate until you need it
yeah they kind of in the nailing
yeah just it sucks like i feel so bad
for them like there's another video well
here's another video that we can't well
we can't play here shows a man in uh
tianjin thank you forcefully holding his
wife and jumping out of the window man
there's an oh we're not there's an
overlay we're not showing that oh good
okay we're not going to show you there's
a ton of those videos of people jumping
out of their balconies
horrible man and i wasn't sure dave you
and i were talking about it before i
don't know if all of these are videos
that are current or if it's somebody
splicing videos over time yes possible
years ago or whatever i have no idea but
one
one is all you have to look at and go
this is just horrific and i'm just
waiting right now for the nba maybe
apple maybe some of these other
companies that are over there right now
disney to to speak out against us and to
say hey this is a humanitarian crisis
right yeah well then they just made
dumbledore straight right so they didn't
get everything wrong they they kind of
moved because we needed a gay dumbledore
character in our next movie what the
fantastic beasts franchise but i just i
don't understand the nba stance on stuff
like this where they can be so woke here
and absolutely just try and toe the line
for everybody apple disney everybody
here can be woke and then something like
this happens in chicago
you don't you don't speak out they can
speak out about ukraine hey we support
the ukrainian citizens
what about what's going on in china
right now do you know many do you many
people when we started covering this
story they had already locked down the
cities you know many people that died
from covet in the entire country of
china since the beginning
one
i'm sorry reported by china one one
person
they have a zero coveted policy which
obviously works because they just had 23
000 cases yesterday
in that city right but so you know that
that's apparently a great policy that's
going to work and so they basically seal
you in because if they kill you they
also kill the virus right so that's the
bonus yeah if someone uh welds you in
your house it's not because they're
going to open the door again i think
that's enough yeah i don't think they're
going to come back around and swing
around yeah that's a very final move so
you might want to get out they don't
have a lot of you know torches to come
and cut you out they got a deal on
welders though yeah you might want to
break off a leg of a chair or something
whittle it down make a spear let's fight
dude broken can you be like such a
stepford wife by your own government too
that you'd be willing to do that to
another human being no questions asked
and you're right about the nba and
everything else but it's like of course
they go where the money is i mean
there's no doubt that it's just a
soulless
yeah there's no absolutely
and it's amazing that it's not even like
they did this in the 1920s and they did
this now this is the same world we're
all living in with the information
readily available and people still
support it blindly with no problem how
about having some balls mark cuban how
about any of these guys who own these
franchises standing up and saying you
know what that's wrong yeah i don't care
if we don't sell a jersey in that
country ever again or if none of their
billions of people ever watch another
game again i don't care how about having
some balls how about having some morals
how about that instead of making people
wear masks to dallas mavericks games and
to lakers home games and to the the nets
not letting kyrie irving play because he
wasn't vaccinated in the city yeah how
about standing up for something that
actually matters where people are dying
you [ __ ] pardon my language i just
no you're right no you don't pardon it
you know these people have a problem
though because in this day and age
everything can be filmed right and this
stuff behind
behind the curtain years ago never got
out but now we know how they treat
people in real time yeah i don't know
how it gets out of there but this stuff
is coming out daily oh absolutely
well that's why they're trying to
constantly
lock everything down you can't go to
certain websites in china you can't
you can't get outside you can't get
information from where you are outside
into the real world that's why they keep
they keep on locking it down and that's
why we get so mad about it here is
because down the road
that could be us exactly yeah because we
are all humans we all have the same
tendencies
those bad people can be over here easily
that's why people get so mad right when
they shut down cell service and the
internet yeah pretty soon it's you're
gonna know there when i when i swore a
minute ago i was actually quoting one of
my favorite people because he knows how
donald trump feels about
alec
china
no
oh he's one of ours for this guy i want
to catch aids no yeah that's that's
definitely not that's the one button
good call oh my gosh thank you for
getting the right one he killed me and
an election
but still creepy video cnn shanghai
reporter david culver explains how
authorities are keeping people in their
homes uh dave before i go just clarify
you're shut in there's like a paper
barrier keeping you from exiting going
to the food market where you are called
a seal you dummy it's a piece of paper
yeah that well for one the food market's
not even open the folks who work at the
food market are also locked down but
yeah i can't go outside that door
there's a seal if i do physically i
could do it but i would break the seal
and there's repercussions for that you
have to have a community worker escort
you to pick up food deliveries if you're
lucky enough to get them and to get the
government distributions if they happen
to come it's bizarre
wow if they happen to come yeah that's
uh well if the government decides
you can eat today
right
he looks like we're winona ryder at the
end of beetlejuice a little bit yeah
with the like scully dead eyes anyway
i'm not condoning this but i think
taping cnn reporters into their homes in
china isn't the worst thing china's ever
done yeah um it's a little based just a
little bit at least they can finally
give some honest reporting of i'm hungry
yeah exactly scared
good thing it's not just uh stelter
there he's like i'm fine
[Laughter]
might help the host of reliable sources
she had a few libby's yeah why did you
send me to china steal him into his so
hungary uh great it's like that robot
i'm just around the airport camera boys
the hungry the robot that holds its s's
i'm not a robot more of a kiosk can i
get some dumplings in here please
what do you mean there's no doordash
i guess my body will just eat itself for
six months i'll be fine oh he's got a
good sword
oh yeah he's got a good 12. brian
seltzer like the before and afters don't
look any different it's like hey you
haven't had food in six months and you
wow you look the same uh the end of this
got a lot of stored there's like the guy
in seven who just like eats the
bottomless food
and emaciated brian stelter is a scary
thought though yeah yeah yeah randy
jackson look at look you know oh yeah
yeah yeah
he's 36. yeah
he looks better now
than he would yeah
all that loose skin it's like just just
be you yeah um
do we go are we going to go right to the
we have some i think we got a couple
minutes oh good go to the gaster do you
want to keep i don't know what do you
guys think because it's uh you know the
signals were confusing they were they
were it's a real problem with
communication
do we go to the guests now and signals
we're good now or do we have a minute uh
we probably have a couple of minutes
okay okay okay so let's talk
yeah it only gets better so in in
guangzhou uh all 18 million citizens
were mandatorily tested oh my gosh
yeah because that's working out really
well
is it the
back-end test
uh no that was the the pete
test as they like to call it the charles
schwab and his brother
yeah
i hear that's the most accurate one yeah
that's the best way to get it that's
what china told me oh that's the way we
like to test that's what you're gonna
request put it in my mouth
terrible my mother effing knows
it's an ass to mouth test
all right now just open up can we do
this the other way no no you've already
done this this is scientific times
there's a limit to be are you a
scientist don't argue with the science
do you want nine guys wearing paint
suits to beat
you're on the other side of the wall
right now well it's your atm swab and
shut it well you know you remember when
when we had issues uh in texas when
texas kind of froze over pretty much the
entire state and everybody
don't remember was panicked
yeah yeah yeah you definitely remember
that when alex jones came to visit us
helicopter that was great um
obviously he's still thinking about it
he's still there
no but you saw the panic buying so
that's what's happening in the rest of
the chinese cities right now especially
those who are starting to get a few
cases because i think what triggered
this was something like under a thousand
cases that they saw and they
automatically started closing stuff down
well other cities are actually going
through panic buying where stores are
starting to be looted stores are running
out of stuff because they're like oh our
city could be next right so what i mean
obviously if you're in a major chinese
city
that thinks it could be next what would
you do you would of course go and buy
everything that you could get your hands
on yeah stockpile die and so that your
family i mean imagine having a baby
right now i'd be terrified especially
there
one that you kept now that their one
child policy is a little bit different a
little bit it's been lifted yeah exactly
what if it's a female imagine
imagine not having enough baby food yeah
and mom doesn't have enough food to be
able to produce the kind of milk that
she needs to to be able to nourish the
baby so breastfeeding is probably out
imagine being in that case what would
you do
in a government that has disarmed you
and told every one of its citizens that
conformity is the goal
what would you do
they have to revolt i mean you're
starving people out because of omicron
because well this is killed we don't
want you to get sick so we're gonna
starve you and kill you right and we're
gonna we're going to make you so
depressed that you're going to be more
willing to jump out of a window than try
to make it another day yeah that's the
best example of the government just
using this situation to go well we're
going to turn up our power meter we're
going to make it
you you can't say anything because we're
going to lock you in your your house and
we're not going to feed you
you're literally going to the point
where you're jumping out of your
balcony because you have no other option
yeah it's either well it's either a slow
painful death or a quick sudden one yeah
yeah and you can and the government goes
well well we're the government
you gave us all the power we're just
going to keep and that control is always
easy more when you heard people into
cities yeah of course and all cities are
run by one party all major cities are
run by one party in this country so
that's the kind of thing that you have
to really be aware of you know you look
what happened in the subway you put
people on mass transit you put people on
a dependency of being in a condensed new
york city is a great example there's no
getting out if they were to dial up the
power well it was i mean new york in a
lot of ways was you know it's sort of
the opposite here in the sense of they
removed all the authority from the
people that needed the authority over
them
you know it's like we gotta let
criminals go and do an open door policy
and then we need to attack people that
have masks on yeah don't have masks on
that's saying and you know that and i'm
into a theater near you it's just this
is stuff we all we talk about all the
time no it's 21 days later except it's
been two and a half years
and zombies would be way easier to
figure out it would be like we could
figure that i'm like all right you shoot
them in the head
take care of them get them out yeah
she'll take care of it all yeah
just sucks
and as much as news reports or social
media can help first-hand story accounts
really
matter they do that's right absolutely
story lives matter the problem is the
ccp does everything it can to limit uh
the dissemination of information
including creepy ass warning signs
do not post pandemic related messages
online do not enter or leave beijing
without permission
spies are among us leaks may happen in
an instant
watch your own mouth or face punishment
these are wow that's very nice right
watch your mouth
dude it's disgusting and so we are
extremely lucky to have on our guest uh
calling in from shanghai who for obvious
reasons can't be named
[Music]
do we have the mug club member from
shanghai joining us now
hello
hello how are you doing
i'm good how about you hey
i'm doing fantastic i would imagine yeah
you're i figured you didn't have
anywhere to be
um yeah a little bit
uh so
can you give us a picture of what it's
like in shanghai right now like is it
better or worse than the media is
showing
um well
okay so i'm
i mean i'm fairly privileged um you know
um and i'm in a neighborhood which with
a lot of expats so um we're kind of
doing uh a lot better than a lot of the
uh lower socioeconomic
um chinese um
as at the moment
so we're able to get a little bit of
food delivered every few days
you know a little bit of fruit
a little bit of vegetables
we can hunt online to find out who has
um to some some food and and and
find someone who's able to deliver who
has the very special pass who's allowed
to be on the road and and pay them an
exorbitant amount of money to actually
um get the food delivered and so but
but it's just what is actually available
is um very very sporadic yeah
i mean were you i guess if you're
getting a little bit of food you
probably weren't that prepared like was
there any
notice given to even want to prepare for
anything
it was really really quick um the the
total lockdown was really quick it was
kind of announced that it was going to
be happening
in like a day
um and
and it was supposed to be for four days
so um so we got together uh enough for
about six days and now we're i think
yeah we're two and a half weeks in
so yeah wow well the good news is 14
days only turned into two and a half
years so yeah right we have that going
forward absolutely
uh
when they when they announced that did
did you see everybody running out to
panic by or were people by and large
believing that the government was going
to take care of them through whatever
period of time that this was going to be
so everyone started
buying
as much as they could but um most of the
the shops that already kind of um closed
down because
in our neighborhood
we'd already been told we'd already
before the lockdown we had already
kind of been in a stay-at-home
uh don't go to work phase so we'd
already been
work had been shut down but we hadn't
been locked in our apartment so
the local neighborhood shops were
already and restaurants were already
closed so we couldn't get deliveries
most of us here don't have cars um and
so we rely on on deliveries where i mean
i've got an electric scooter and we go
to the um shop and we we shop for you
know a couple of bags of groceries at a
time um and and so so that's it so you
get delivery um but now you know it's um
yeah it's whatever you can scrounge
around
um to what is what you eat really yeah i
didn't know that the stores had been
closed down prior to that so that makes
it even worse i mean it's it sounds like
you know horrifically bad i know you're
in a little bit better part of town
where
do you how do you think people or do you
have any information on how people are
faring in maybe areas that are a little
bit a little bit tougher maybe a little
less yeah the videos we've seen kind of
accurate um yeah you know of with the
suicides and that sort of thing to be
blunt oh yeah
yeah
it's um it's tough it's really bad um
and uh
yeah it's i can just you know pray for
them and and pray that you know
you know the lockdowns are lifted soon
we're hearing that some neighborhoods
that have got no cases in the last five
days are starting to be lifted that they
can actually um go out for essentials
from their neighborhoods um and the
neighborhoods are very small by the way
um so to the clinton store it's very
small
right
exactly that's the problem the stores
are all closed and the ones that even
are allowed to be open have no stock
because there haven't been any
deliveries from trucks and things like
that um we were able to just before the
big lockdown happened we were a group of
friends of mine able to order a delivery
from costco there is a costco here now
um and um there was very limited um
deliveries available um because um
they're
the
shelves are empty yeah well if you guys
had bought something other than ketchup
and mustard that would have been a great
idea but you have a lot of that
they do well that's all that matters
they have toilet paper the condiments
works with everything do you have uh do
you think there's like an end in sight
do you actually see this as coming to an
end
there like would you have like a little
bit of hope i mean
maybe that's an odd question it has to
right we have it has to because i mean
they've they've closed the the shanghai
port they've closed the shanghai stock
exchange i mean everything's closed they
they are losing billions of dollars a
day and at this stage it's just saving
face and which is a very chinese thing
to do they have to save face um and it's
they put their this is their policy zero
covered so and they can't be seen to
back down from that because that would
be losing face but they are losing
so much um
money and also saving a losing face
in the world that they can't deliver on
on all the products that everyone are
needing in the world um but it's just i
mean they've done everything that we
we've been doing two covert tests today
um for most of this week um you know uh
having to uh and it's just you know
people are literally starving i mean we
got a we got a a delivery of um bacon
and sausages the other day and eggs and
so we've pretty much been eating eggs
and bacon and sausages um for most meals
um and then i've got a half a jar of
peanut butter and some old um soggy
graham crackers that we found at the
back of the pantry and so we've been
eating that for a while
but i've got two i've got two kids as
well and um
we have to do online school as well um
you know doing that at the same time and
it's yeah it's fun and games are you
worried about your kids with the
policies i i mean obviously you are but
i mean what is the scariest aspect of
that i mean and i don't mean to ask that
personally but you mentioned having them
yes so the biggest worry especially in
the early um days were um if a kid
turned up um
positive and the parents weren't um the
child was taken from the parents and put
into these quarantine camps um and
without the parents and without um an
advocate and um and no one in these
camps um these you know quarantine
facilities whatever unite black want to
call them um it speaks english um and i
mean to be perfectly honest my kids um
speak
chinese better than i do but still
nowhere near fluently and um and that's
i mean that that's just not going to
happen that's you know that that's the
time when we get the guys to go down to
the square and get taint you know um
yeah
so
you you don't you don't take my kids
from me um and that's that's when things
are gonna get you know that's the line
it's just it's so brutally just
dehumanizing to do that to people like i
i a lot of what i'm seeing i just can't
even believe like it's disgusting what
they're doing to cats let alone human
beings yeah you know and uh
i guess being
being from australia like how would you
compare
your situation now what was going on
earlier in the pandemic
oh well that's just disgusting as well
what was happening in australia
especially um the state of victoria um
but but even
at the height of the pandemic in in
australia in victoria you were allowed
within five kilometers of your home and
you were allowed to go to the to the
shopping centers and get groceries and
there were groceries at the at the
shopping centers you were just you know
shot with rubber bullets if you tried to
peacefully you know march and protest
against the lockdowns you know um
it's you know you can't leave your
apartment and um shanghai is a city of
26 million people so
unless you are a multi-multi-millionaire
you've got a small apartment and so
we've got four of us living in this
small apartment and
my son's 11 and he loves to play soccer
and
basketball and run around and he's
jumping out of his skin yeah
yeah i can imagine well so we're
the reports that we get talk about the
cases that are happening right now but
they don't necessarily give us like
death totals because we know that with
omicron thankfully it was much much much
less deadly and the symptoms i was
reading that most people won't even know
that they're sick and this was from an
article i think on cnn so lest we get in
trouble uh from this they were saying
that most people are asymptomatic and
that they wouldn't even know that they
were sick in china specifically talking
about this so this is the omicron
variant right going around right now and
a lot of people may be getting sick but
are do you see do you see any numbers on
on people dying like was there this like
mad run up to like people are dying
everywhere we have to lock this thing
down no
not at all when when the school got shut
down with um with my kids um i think
there was 96 cases in shanghai at that
time
and it's just
it's really confusing because they want
to scare the absolute crap out of the
population um about the virus
by you know to keep them everyone in
there um
in their apartments they've got
megaphones on drones they've got
megaphones on robotic dogs that are
going through the neighborhoods very
creepy yeah and yeah headless robotic
dogs with megaphones yeah
you couldn't have partnered with bose to
build a speaker in like i had to tape a
megaphone onto it geez yeah well it
doesn't look dystopian that way gonna
make it look terrifying yeah buy those
dogs oh nice yeah
um
yeah
yeah they don't they don't shoot them
when you you get
tested positive um
yeah
um
but um
you know it's it's um
where were we oh yeah well the death
rates or anything like that yeah
it's so they're trying to get they're
trying to scare the crap out of everyone
but at the same time they're saying that
no one has died from it so i don't know
i don't don't understand the mixed
messages the
officially um that there is no one died
in shanghai from this wave right zero
none do you believe that none
um
you know
i i don't know i i've
i'm will not have the fisa mrna vaccine
because of what i've heard um
um with the mrna technology but i have
and i've kind of had to but i've had the
the chinese
vaccine because it's pretty much like
just saline solution anyway but um
they took the placebo the placebo yeah
yes it's it's basically um it's based on
the dead virus um vaccine just like
chickenpox vaccine like
all the other vaccines we've had um and
so i didn't feel
bad about that because it's not new
technology it's all technology um and so
it's not as effective but it seems to
have been
you know not uh working as in not
killing people from yeah the virus
that's it's just strange to me that
they're saying nobody has died from this
um i i mean it's hard for us to believe
it because jumping out of high rises
yeah 100
in the first wave people absolutely died
i mean you know there were
pictures of the morgues being overrun
and all of that i mean allegedly of
course um apparently um some have might
have said um maybe
those were shots actually you don't die
from covet if you're shot so
of course yes
one might say different um but
but apparently i mean
you know i haven't heard of anyone um
dying from this wave but i mean as as
you know the the information here is so
filtered um our main method of of uh
communication over here is an app called
wechat yeah um and and that is 100
monitored and um and um you know edited
and scrutinized by the ccp at all times
yeah we used to chat yeah yeah it should
be
not so much anymore yeah
well well i wish you a lot of luck we
really appreciate you calling and i i
hope it lifts for you very soon i i
can't thank you enough for taking the
time to to share your story with us and
uh thoughts and prayers i that sounds
just pathetic that's all we can offer
but yeah prayers to you and your family
not a problem at all i'm i'm i'm happy
to happy to chat to the to the to the
team yeah well and once you once you get
out of there um give us a give us a
shout and maybe we can actually have you
on if you're gonna follow up yeah yes we
can get a little bit more information
i'll be back in australia i think and
for good i'm getting out of this place
early early june there you go
all right man
all right so everybody take it easy
thank you so much
[Music]
scary as hell it's a real guy in
shanghai so i think it's important to
mention this is what happens when you
hear people say like well i'm a
communist i'm this this is what you give
up when you give up your rights this is
what happens this is what the government
does when they cause the sort of mass
confusion any government does you have
nobody dying from this disease they're
starving their people yeah they're
killing their people
this is the safe face yeah like you said
like to say faith is part of the of that
culture is to even if you're in wrong if
you're in the wrong
you save the face yeah hold up pull up
cnn real quick apparently we're going
back to covering
oh oh
i think i should feed a bagel's face to
flies
oh
what's he saying there we put all the
cats in the bags we're following the
science the cdc is issuing new guidance
for masks on public trains and planes
for the next two weeks they're going to
keep the mass mandate for that you know
that's it
so apparently apparently getting to
almost 70 percent fully vaccinated and
having omicron come through and and you
know basically
after people getting that you know
getting some kind of ability to fight
this thing off a little bit that that's
not enough we got to do more i don't
know where it came from we're gonna
close your lab in wuhan no oh no don't
discover that for two years even though
you said it before it hits
i would i don't i'm a scientist not a
doctor you're a pretty blonde thing
have you ever seen a soft man with a one
inch
how about a sand fly yeah oh you ever
seen a have you ever seen snoopy lose
his head
i got a whole lab
it's for science i'm a monster
i made aids worse all right well anyway
thank you all for tuning in today uh we
are going to get off this platform
because obviously we're talking about
real issues and that's no good here
not allowed
not a lot you can see me in virginia
beach the funny part
uh but anyway please comment comment
comment we'd love to hear your thoughts
and uh we're gonna head off to detroit
we're gonna be back we have uh monday
yeah yeah is that right or is there
something tomorrow no no show tomorrow
yeah i think we're heading off to uh
yeah but don't worry we're gonna be back
don't get all whining yeah well they
said all right
if you don't go to detroit you're sent
there well yeah that's true there's that
they'll be taking a train anywhere
that's where we're going but we love our
detroit fans i do they need hardy folk
they have overcome a lot of them are
thick a lot of them are thinking of
moving to shanghai for better conditions
that's true
less fear
um anyway
piss off youtube yeah
[Music]